Kimberly RF aquateri in the Eastern
Mediterranean is if I can put it let's
let's starting point for the military
operation this is where the aircraft
have been and will continue to take off
from and then make a journey directly
south pretty much three and a half four
hours uh towards Sudan I'm joined by uh
Wing Commander Richard Fox who is the
commanding officer of the expeditionary
wing
which has carried out these operations
uh very busy few days for you tell me
about it it has me so we started uh
ramping up planning a process about
seven days ago or so and I have since
then flown in
um an enormous number of UK military
personnel and equipment to begin
preparing for any military operation
that we're asked to do in support of the
fcdo so planning has been intensive and
detailed and several options have been
worked through to give all possible um
options available for the government to
allow some possible so you're using two
types of aircraft the C-130 Hercules and
an a400m so to the non-military sort of
Aviation geek if I can put it like that
sure why are these aircraft good for an
operation like this well those two and
uh the the C-17 which you can see behind
me as well which is which is used in the
greater aspects of the operation these
are tactical Edge Transport Aircraft so
we can use these to more austere
locations and they don't need all of the
the the AIDS that you will get at a
large international airport so we can
use them in a tactical environment and
better for a situation like in a
humanitarian operation or an evacuation
as we're doing at the moment in Sudan
and specifically in this case the
Airfield you've got to land at just
north of the castle had to hostile
environment what are the what are the
challenges for your Pilots
um the the challenge is the very Dynamic
uh changing nature of the picture on the
ground obviously the the fighting that
has been going on for a couple of weeks
now is hard to predict and so
um considering the risk to our people is
utmost uh so we are mitigating all the
risks where we absolutely can but
ensuring we're doing absolutely
everything that we can to ensure the
safe and efficient recovery of all those
entitled British citizens back to a
place of safety and a few of your
aircraft have come back what are you
hearing what's the reports you're
getting coming back about what it's like
yeah I mean fortunately we've had no
issues uh from the the crews who've come
back from the first missions that took
place early this morning so the
operation is conducting as well as I'd
like it to to conduct and hopefully
we'll continue doing so safely and
expeditionally win Commander Richard
folks thank you very much well we've
just in the last half an hour or so seen
another
and we expect one is coming inbound as
well with the first evacuees their land
actually at lanaka Air Base uh just
around the coast but these flights will
uh keep continuing through the night and
into tomorrow as the situation allows
them to